January 1st 2009 we will request another
25 billion then on June 15th we will ask
for 50 billion on September 30th another
50 billion then provided there's a
rebound in new car sales on December
15th 100 in 2008 sales of Ford cars and
trucks fell 21% at General Motors the
figure was 23% in Chrysler saw whopping
30% to climb in sales last year
supporters of the Big Three automakers
argue that the government needs to
provide Detroit with at least 50 billion
dollars in taxpayer money in order to
save the American car industry that's an
addition to the 25 billion in federally
subsidized loans they've already
received President Barack Obama agrees
we must bailout Chrysler GM and Ford
so while taxpayers end up rewarding
Detroit for making unprofitable cars
hard to believe isn't it that the
Detroit car manufacturers the city that
bequeathed to America the Aztec gremlin
citation and Grenada which
president-elect Obama called the worst
car Detroit ever built could have lost
so much money in the last year while
many commenters in union advocates paint
Detroit's economic troubles as a
consequence of the financial crisis the
troubles of the big three long predated
the current mess in 2007 for instance
the Japanese car manufacturer Toyota
pulled in massive profits while selling
fewer cars than General Motors who
during the same period were losing
billions we asked University of Maryland
professor peter Murray see why Detroit
was losing so much money while Toyota
was cleaning up the basic problem is
their labor costs are too high they have
legacy costs from the past and they're
burdened by debt it's absolutely absurd
to think that you can pay $75 an hour in
wages and benefits and make cars
successfully in North America or
anyplace else the United States has a
competitive advantage in making cars if
the labor costs are adequately aligned
because those automakers are expanding
there's nothing particularly superior
about the
Engineering in the Toyota but bail had
supporters using much disputed figures
provided by the automotive Institute an
auto industry associated think-tank
claimed that if the big three are
allowed to fail approximately three
million jobs will be lost but that's not
going to happen the the transplants the
Japanese manufacturers the Koreans the
imports can't supply the entire US
automobile market the domestic
automobile factories would be reopened
by someone else if Detroit is immune
from market pressures exerted on its
competitors well other countries choose
to ignore our subsidies and continue
providing jobs to hundreds of thousands
of American workers if union bosses
insist on securing exorbitant wages for
its members wage is far higher than any
other car manufacturer in the world but
American consumers aren't willing to pay
extra costs for an inferior product
should Washington built the taxpayer to
fund cars that didn't want in the first
place let me ask you this why should a
waitress making $12 in Indiana center
tax dollars to Washington subsidize
someone would it pay package equal to
about $75 an hour Americans are
skeptical well there's some support for
the money already loaned to Chrysler and
General Motors a majority are against
providing any further assistance to the
big three but that's of no consequence
to President Obama or your
representatives in Congress because
bailout mania has come to Washington and
both Wall Street and Detroit are
standing in line hands outstretched
waiting for politicians to intervene in
the economy and save American jobs
whether you like it or not a reason TV
I'm Michael Moynihan America's the
greatest land of
waiter nothing congressman with all due
respect we are not talking about a gift
or a subsidy we are talking about a loan
alone on which you will mostly certainly
default yes